Albert is next Albertson New Jersey how
are you Albert Oh could be better could
be worse days how can I help so I just
found out last month I'm basically going
to be weight off of my new job which
I've only been in for three months I'm
about to be laid off in this October so
what do you get paid uh with bonus and
everything about sixty one thousand okay
what do you do um I'm an original
Account Manager in mind transfer company
for a what money transfer company money
transfer company okay all right and so
what is you been out you've been knowing
this for a month how's the job hunt
going
it's been really aggressive I've been
pretty much kind of just hand over fist
just aggressively applying for jobs I'm
meeting with career counselors going to
job fairs you know pretty much the whole
nine yards yeah so have you got any
offers no not yet no I've currently in
in the interview process to hopefully
potentially leading to a job offer but
so far it's still within the working
stages anyway my question is like this
is the second time I've been laid off
within the past two years I've worked
for three different companies since then
first time I got laid off back in 2017
I've been I work for about ten months
during that ten months obviously I
decided to fill the gaps by going back
to school
it's a new certifications um kind of
meaning a little bit in my savings but I
felt like you know hopefully messing
education would be a better return on
investment future
monster shirt eventually I landed this
job back in May and then Austin you know
companies had to do some downsizing and
now part of a huge way off
and I just need to know if if
financially I'm in a good place
while I'm aggressive looking for this
job because you know it's about a month
and I'm still not haven't had concrete
offers and I'm looking to see if there's
a way if if I should be doing something
else different or if I should be
regretted and the hours are when you're
working out 40 okay
won't you pick up an extra job
delivering pizzas Bank the money yeah I
mean I'm not afraid you know take a step
back ya know I'm not telling just saying
do that permanently I'm saying you have
a month left and you could bank to an
extra $2,000 I give you a little extra
cushion how much money you got in
savings I have about 17,000 you said
certs are you in technology no money
transfer okay so the certification was
in that in that field I had three
different certifications one in digital
marketing one in data term management
and then another one customer management
okay well data management that'll be
paid more than 61 grand if you're any
good at it you may be brand new though
you may be just take an entry stuff
especially in Jersey so um you know a
good data engineer is worth a lot more
than that in most places and there's a
shortage so if you've got the ability to
mind data and manage data from a
marketing perspective and you can prove
that to companies
you're pretty valuable you're pretty
good commodity as far as that goes and
but you know you've got seventeen
thousand if you want to work an extra
job I'd work something extra and pile up
some cash because the bigger pile of
cash you got the less desperate you are
and hopefully they're giving you some
kind of a package as well when you go
out the door and you know it's just the
rough and tumble out there listen there
is no such thing folks for any of you
and it's true of you Albert that's true
me there's no such thing as
security there's no such thing it's
mythology the only thing that gives you
security is you have a skill set that is
marketable in the marketplace and when
you have a marketable skill set
you've always got security when you know
how to sell you can always find a job
when you have you know you're in the
technology field right now you always
find a job you're a nurse you can always
find a job you know he's find money to
come in you know and say you've got a
marketable skill in the marketplace you
are your only job security this idea
that you're gonna get some company that
is actually going to take care of you
it's just mythology and so you're just
experience the rough-and-tumble of the
early years of your career path and you
didn't do anything wrong it sounds like
it's a massive layoff it's not personal
it wasn't aimed at you you got a little
experience under your belt I'm gonna
send you a copy of ken Coleman's book
the proximity principle I think you
might be hunting for your job wrong I
think you might be just filling out
applications left and right and that's
bad or you might be just tweaking your
resume that's bad go to Ken Coleman show
comm and download his resume guidelines
his interview guidelines and read the
book I'm gonna send you which is called
the proximity principle both of those
will help you immensely in this job hunt
do it immediately as soon as you get the
book I'm gonna put you on hold Kelly's
gonna pick up and we will get you signed
up for that folks you can you can build
an algorithm an Autobot fill out job
applications and fill out 50,000 job
applications on monster.com by the end
today or zip recruiter or whatever else
let me tell many job offers you'll get
zero because I hired 260 260 people last
year we had 22,000 applications you do
not get out of that pile by just put by
just entering into the pile so not how
it works you got to build a relationship
with somebody inside the organization
Coleman I'll show you how to do that
with the proximity principle